today we are joined by Pandora box from
RuPaul's Drag Race season 2 All-Stars
one and six critically and also the new
to be showed the dish drag queen
comedian Pandora box really a pleasure
to have you on today oh thank you and I
thank you for calling me a comedian I
appreciate that well it's in the notes
um so listen I mean we as as you know
there is there is nothing hotter right
now among some enclaves of American
politics than targeting what is
essentially the free expression of drag
performers we have seen this growing
prevalence of anti-drag Hysteria
everything from complaining about drag
shows and and reading events and and so
on and so forth within within the
community what is the perspective and
the attitude to what's going on is it a
surprise is it shocking
um I mean I think that we all kind of
think it's just a load of
and honestly and we are just an easy
target because
there's still people that don't
understand drag there's still people
that think uh they're still the toxic
masculinity that's ever prevalent that
you know guys are supposed to wear pants
and women are supposed to wear dresses
and if you confuse that uh it's wrong
somehow so it's kind of like this we've
gone back to what we were in like the
80s and 90s basically well not
completely because we've come a long way
but some of the people that are uh that
are the loudest are really it makes me
feel like when I first started doing
drag and it was definitely not accepted
by mainstream I want to get to some of
the misconceptions in a moment but one
of the things I've observed and I'm
curious whether you see this the same
way is that some of the tropes that were
often used to attack gay men say 10
years ago maybe 15 maybe closer to 20
you know 10 to 20 years ago are now
being applied
separately but similarly to the trans
community and to the drag Community one
of the ones I'm thinking of is the idea
of again remember formerly the gay man
but now either the drag queen or the
trans person of the opportunist
pedophile who is using whatever method
they can think of to try to get
themselves in situations where they can
carry out acts against children it seems
like it's the same talking points just
applied to a different community
yeah it definitely is because in our
society there was one thing that you can
label someone or a group people
uh that will make them ostracized
immediately or people will they will
have fear they will have hate and that's
to call someone a pedophile so that's
what's being done again it's like a fear
tactic and it's ridiculous like I don't
even really like kids so
like
when it comes yeah it's just it's just
an easy it's an easy label to slap on
somebody and then it scares a bunch of
people who can't be bothered to do any
kind of research or anything like that
because uh uh there are some pedophiles
out there for sure uh they're not drag
queens they're uh priests yeah and in
fact a new new report about uh I forget
which country it is where it turns out 5
000 cases of abuse tied to the Catholic
church and that might I don't want to
say the wrong country so I'll just skip
but there's a new report about that yeah
when it comes to misconceptions can you
just talk a little bit about what are
the main misconceptions because if you
were to listen to right wing talk radio
you get the idea that any drag event is
sort of a uh Satan and sometimes
drug-fueled event with violence crimes
sexual assault I mean I don't even know
what they think happens but it's
certainly not what happens it sounds
like to me I mean the biggest thing is
that the people speaking about drag
shows have never been to an actual drag
show other than Kerry Lake though to be
fair it sounds like after it sounds
Kerry Lake was at a show she she was and
Barbara Seville has the receipts to
prove that right uh yeah Kerry lake is a
complete liar yeah but I I interrupted
you though so a lot of the people
commenting don't know anything about
what goes on oh no it's clear that
they've never actually been to a drag
show or you know maybe even seen a drag
queen in real life and
um
because they're speaking like that's not
what happens and like at least drag like
drag brunches are very popular right now
it's it's a big thing for drag and I
just lost my earbud but hey
um it's a big thing dry brunches are
really big right now and uh you know who
goes to drag brunches the most is
straight women
and they go and they have a good time
and get a little drunk because they want
to get away from their husbands or
and it's just fun and I will say that I
do many shows and there's never any
children at these shows there's never
children at a Drag Brunch there's never
children at like most of the shows I do
if there's a pride event yeah there's
there's kids there but it's it's told to
me or to any performer that it's family
friendly and so you have to to you know
I like to swear a lot I you know I alter
my ACT to uh accommodate that and and
kids are just fascinated by it because
I've I've had young kids ask me
uh like family members or friends kids
and who don't understand drag and I just
say hey it you know on Halloween when
you like to get dressed up that's it
that's John I do that for a living and
they're like all right I get it
now what about the events that
are actually tailored to children so for
example these these drag time story
hours that have been the subject of much
controversy I admit I've never been to
one is it simply that there are drag
performers reading to kids like is that
it it sounds pretty innocuous to me
um yeah I mean it really is drag queens
reading books to kids a lot of the books
are very diverse and inclusive and it
speaks to kids
uh you know who might be just feeling
like they're different and uh if I knew
some of the things I know now like if
there was a drag queen Story Hour when I
was a kid or it would have saved me uh
so much pain so much
so much everything because I
you know I was very like suicidal and
depressed and didn't know and it was
different and didn't know why I was
different and if if I had seen that I
would have been like oh I I think I
understand it now and really it is it is
drag Wayne's reading books to kids and
it's not like they just drop a busload
of kids off of this place their parents
are with them and that's the biggest
thing for me too is these these people
speaking out against it and protesting
it it's like well you're not their
parent and if we tried to parent your
kid you would be complaining about I
this is my kid I'm gonna do what I want
one of the um lines that I'm hearing
increasingly is that along with social
media and movies and shows you know they
wrap a whole bunch of things into this
but but one of the things that's heard
is the the drag time story hours and the
exposure to drag performances is quote
turning kids trans now this seems crazy
for a number of reasons but first of all
I hate that we even have to do this can
you just remind the audience that drag
performer and trans person are two
different things
yeah they totally are like I am a drag
queen uh I consider myself gender fluid
uh
just because when I was growing up that
wasn't even a thing because I don't feel
like I'm
either or and it depends on what the day
sometimes and and that's okay because
we're just we're forced to be in these
constructs of male female him or and uh
there are many uh people that do drown
there's also like uh
women that you're trying
to like really phrase it right so nobody
gets mad at me but it's just it
encompasses a lot and there's drag Kings
and uh you every drag performer does not
want to be the opposite sex
uh for me it's more about entertaining
it's a show
and then there are some trans performers
who do vote they're trans and they're
they're a drag performer so there is
there is definitely a difference
and you cannot make someone trans like
it just
doesn't happen it it it's something they
just know they just know that they are
in a body that doesn't feel right and in
a society that is forcing these rules
upon them and they just don't feel that
that's that's who they are
when it comes to the legislation that's
being proposed in different parts of the
country I see many people say listen I
don't have anything against drag queens
or drag queens reading to kids
I just don't care about that so much
that I'm going to worry about the
legislation can you talk about why
people who don't care about drag per se
should still be concerned about the
legislation
um I think people should be concerned
about the legislation because it's
taking away rights from American
citizens which these people are always
about it's America it's free we're all
treated equal and uh we're not being
treated equal and if they're taking away
one group of people's rights they're
gonna they're gonna try to take away
other people's rights and it's it's
happening you can see this this shift of
this very Ultra
religious conservative
uh group of people that are really
really and have been making concerted
efforts to make these changes and to
make it so it's there's no freedom of
religion it's one religion that's what
we're supposed to be and it's One race
that's what we're supposed to be and
that's happening and so uh the trans
Community is an easy target because
there's still so many people that don't
understand what trans is and
the fact like with the bathroom walls
and all that sorry if I said
but uh it's like
you've gone to the bathroom with a trans
person a trans person has been in that
bathroom with you before I'm sure of it
but you didn't know because they just
want to use the bathroom
like that's it
and people have probably met somebody
trans and never knew and because they're
not like wearing a label that says Hey I
want to be trans they just want to fit
in and they just want to live their life
and and and feel what they feel in the
inside they want to be happy about
themselves
last thing I want to ask you about you
know people in my audience have called
and said David where do you think this
is going generally speaking what what's
the next thing and you know when we look
at the history of it we see that there
was this like I said 10 12 15 years ago
the focus from these groups was was
mostly gay men lesbians they were never
that concerned with there were phases
but they were never that concerned with
lesbians the gay men was a focus they've
shifted over now to to the trans
Community uh to the drag Community Etc
my guess is at some point they will move
on to the next thing in a sense that may
be good for the trans Community but I
worry about whoever is next in the
Crosshair so like what's your
perspective on how this all ends well it
made me laugh where they never really
came for lesbians it's as hard and
that's straight men I think a straight
men have a lesbian fantasy so they can
still sexualize it and so that's why
they're like oh well you know hey or I
can switch them like oh they just have
to be with the right man right and with
gay men it's because if there's any
effemininity uh they're threatened by it
because we live in a toxic masculine
culture where men have to be men and
that's
a major that's the base of a lot of
these problems is that
and I don't know who they're going to
come for next like after the trans
community
uh drag queens they're just really
I'm happy that at least now there is a
big support system for Trans people and
drag queens and this community because
there are a lot of people speaking out
against it and
I don't know I mean who can they target
next I mean all these white people are
feel like they're being victimized now
because they've been in power forever
and screaming about diversity and uh you
know it's good about black lives matter
and when they say all lives matter it's
just like
we we know that
on the um on the expectations about what
masculinity means do you think there's
been some progress in the last few years
in some areas in the sense of
it seems much more acceptable in popular
culture for you know football players to
talk about therapy or that they cried
like I know that these are small things
but it seems like a little bit there
actually has been some progress in
popular culture in terms of what
masculinity is maybe it's a sign of
things to come I don't know
yeah no I mean I do I definitely feel
like there there's definitely been
change and uh it just it the people that
are speaking out against it tend to be
the loudest yes
um there's many people that accept it
and I don't know we kind of tune it out
because I hear it and I'm like oh God
Marjorie Taylor green shut up uh right
but she's I mean with her it's like
she's loud and she has an agenda and her
agenda is to make herself famous so
after she's not a congress person she's
going to make money she's going to go on
Fox news she's going to be this comment
she's going to do all these things
because she's setting herself up because
she knows I I thought she was stupid but
I think she's she's got a plan which is
to I'm gonna be really terrible and this
one side who will never change because
there are people on that side who I
don't think we'll ever change correct
it's their core and she's appealing to
them because they also just tend to
throw money at these people because I
don't know without a doubt the
fundraising aspect of it is a major
major part of this uh we have been
speaking with Pandora box from RuPaul's
Drag Race season two All-Stars one and
six and the new to be show the dish I so
appreciate your time and insights today
yeah thank you thank you for having me
it's it's a topic that gets me heated
but then I think of like my everyday
life and it's not been affected by
any of this and uh but I have had
friends that have had the protesters at
drag queen story hour and it's also just
like
you know what's scarier a drag queen
reading uh books to kids are you guys
coming with guns and masks and and
processing and scaring these children
they were their parents by the way yeah
a very uh sharp contrast there for sure
really appreciate it thank you yeah
thank you for having me